me as a person who found it offensive no
I mean me and my friends played with
dead people alive people people over in
the middle you know why did you just
couldn't get any we couldn't monetize it
we were from the generation that can't
monetize you think your face looks
leaner than the last time I saw you I
lost five pounds dude I got a sinus
infection though not a good five pound
lost oh yeah I got a sign you can you
hear my nose I'm not congested a sinus
infection make you lose five pounds yeah
I've been sick for weeks
literally nothing you've been sick well
no I've said I've been I've had sinus
infections I've never lost anyway I have
no appetite Wow you don't look percent
well honestly what's the key you know
it's I'm transforming into something
else yeah
takes a while what are you transforming
into the next person I'll be no oh that
remains to be soap it's a cop somebody
who sells insurance hope his name's
Garrett yeah I hope so too dude first of
all honestly number one name that I
cannot it's just built into my system
somehow I can't react about with it
people named Terry yeah and especially
if it's a man I was gonna say I can get
away with the female Terry's guy Terry's
I don't know it's not so much yes yeah I
didn't name you give a kid when you want
them to have a hard life yeah yeah hey
Terry little Terry yeah we had a little
guy named Terry bus this little black
felon he would always drink milk at the
park didn't you had no idea we got it
and he was always aired there how's he
doing now it's a great question I had
something to be said 26 years ago they
didn't were like we're your parents you
know any net he didn't even know no yeah
it's almost like he was just born like
in a birdbath or something
no orléans legend what are you training
for so your trainer you actually train
them for this fight honey you you just
you just did a fight low yeah I had a
fight last year August 25th and then
yeah another another one this year
November 9th same same kid it's the
rematch ok on two so professional fight
no headgear Staples Center it's gonna be
sick man and you guys think you'll sell
it out I think so wow I think so that's
much grace it's a big fight to hold the
whole undercard is professional fights
yeah it's the first view it's like your
first professional yeah fine yeah
oh really yeah London crazy I'm gonna
feed it so far I'm oh oh and one bro
probably beat your brother's ass for
years too didn't you huh we stopped
because we both got him yeah man he's
big dude like it's a thick little Oreo
yeah yeah so so we gotta stop fighting
because we destroy everything yeah you
know in the house right well the
brothers get so big that they'll destroy
everything right chairs tables glass so
we stopped so it's been a minute since I
was and he's got a little bit of a
Flintstone in him to a little more than
he does man you know he's that I noticed
and you couldn't tell if he was like 19
or all like 38 you know yeah the hair
doesn't give it away oh just like the
high and tight for years but I think he
I don't know what it was he just has he
reminds you of every guy who owns like a
nice boat in Florida that yeah yeah yeah
wasn't there a thing where he was gonna
fight someone to you were gonna do it
and there wasn't your dad gonna fight
somebody so we [ __ ] yet yeah dude the
whole family's gonna fight dude I hope
your dad fights that older black guy
he's like uh he's a politician but he's
like from he can't even talk and
everybody's like he's the best and he's
like my dad Jesse's smaller I think
that'd be a great GPA and Jesse small it
just dude that was romance
phenomenal yeah your dad would probably
take care of that he would me I mean
dude who knows go on his Instagram
you'll see all this man does yeah he's
chop wood and Thai tomahawks to his
motorcycle yeah that's always small it
no not my dad he flips tires he chops
wood and he ties tomahawks to his beers
I think I see Smollett beat your dad
you'd have to kill your father I oh yeah
oh yeah
put in ever look at your father no I
know that it couldn't you know there's
no Christmas is over
everything's yeah yeah if Jessie ones
yeah that's why it's all that just he's
smaller
I can't believe if he fought your dad
yeah I think like it historically he's
not so good at defending himself right
that's true right yeah yeah your dad
with I think your honor honestly dude I
have no idea like and I think yeah yeah
I agree yeah but a lot of I'm afraid of
his dad oh noes dad but I'm afraid I'm
afraid guy that would raise you and your
brother I think has got to be insane
that's a good boy it will kill someone
yeah and I appreciate it it's definitely
a property owner yeah it's a real deal
guy yes you know a real deal guy that's
not a guy that's not a music teacher
didn't bring up these two boys you know
what I mean
this is a guy that likes match around a
little bit yeah made you go out and
light the world on fire yeah that owns a
bunch of coal oh no no this guy's not
there was no he didn't read poetry
before dinner you know got into it you
know yeah this guy who mom is probably
also somewhat top right no mom's a sweet
hell mom sweet the exact table and so
I'm go away just like a sweet okay if
you even look at his mom you hear an
oven door opening oh yeah by like a Long
Island mom that's I could also see that
ya get tough notion island [ __ ]
sweetheart sweetheart oh yeah and you
guys are from where Ohio Ohio yeah
oh no hi oh did you greet your friends
with Roman Atwood I was I am yeah I
still AM yeah yeah Roman still have you
met him yeah yeah super cool guy down
earth he's a special dude yeah that's
really cool um dude actually think it's
speaking of fight they had a thing when
I was young called and this is you know
[ __ ] fistfights was a thing and it would
come to colleges when I was in college
and they would it would be two gay men
and this lesbian lady and you'd go watch
them and they would fistfight see
college you should be so much fun yeah
you can't you know now will this PC [ __ ]
now everything's soft yeah that needs to
be great imagine trying to do that now
it's called [ __ ] fighting and we have two
gay guys and it's to first blood so the
first first AIDS blood splatter all done
then we're done with the fight
would be rough now to get away you know
I'm gonna get cancelled just from being
on this yeah yeah you will that's what
watch me say no words yeah I'm the one I
love it can't be cancellation so
apparently it doesn't exist calculation
it doesn't exist yourself yeah it's over
well here's the thing though that's the
thing if you're trying to cancel Trump
yeah he's about to get picked up four
more years but isn't it crazy when you
think like the one of the the president
was a real mean also he was a
businessman right in a shady business
man I think like I'm not I'm not anti
Trump like a lot of you people are like
I don't give a [ __ ] thing you know I
live my life I don't yeah the government
doesn't determine everybody right now
but he's a reality star cardi B was a
reality started yeah president and she's
like the biggest pop sensation it's just
it's all starting to kind of blend
together yeah I think a car - it'll be
the Governor of California who I'm not
even kidding though I mean I think I
think you see what Kim is doing right
now right with the prison reform and
stuff I think it's going in that
direction and I gotta be honest with you
I don't mind I'm not mad at ya I'm ready
for the new world you know who'd be a
sick governor is Kris Kris Jenner yeah
she a bad [ __ ] oh that's the years left
on the planet why not have fun yeah yeah
why not oh hey hold up vision and that's
it probably it's gonna get rough after
50 yeah it's gonna get hot we're saying
literally we're saying literally Kris
Jenner is a good option and I agree with
you yeah it's gonna get rough for
Christmas people are gonna be getting
shield yeah it's gonna be tough I mean
there's a lot of tents yeah there's a
lot of tests you know but also I think
in California like you go to the rest of
America everybody's really kind of just
enjoy you know things are going pretty
cool I feel like out here there's this
this spiderweb like everything's falling
apart like like yeah yeah you do a fist
fighting like that a gay fist fighting
at bars dude I'm from people would go
see it have a blast
booyah who would make an article about
it but nobody really [ __ ] I don't
think is why is watching that [ __ ]
anyone certainly not Yahoo all right
yeah yes I don't think anybody's even
reading these websites do you got you
know like nobody cares the mainstream
stuff nobody cared about Chappelle war
there's three people were mad at
Chappelle's and then everybody's
debating it was like no nobody cared no
it's the it's the yeah the minority
becomes the majority
somehow yeah so now because of like the
amplification of social media yeah it
sucks but I don't think it's do you feel
like it's that a fad I feel like it it
really kind of falls on deaf ears it's
like I think it's the worst thing now as
if people aren't mad at you right like
the worst thing as if people if you're
not controversial it's almost like
you're done the opposite of love is not
hate its indifference which is it that's
a great coil apathy apathy dude like you
imagine imagine like truly no one gave a
[ __ ] about you 100% at least you make
them feel something right I try to get
attention all the time I tweet
everything you know I just tweet out are
you that well I mean I try to doubt
things hoping to you know you know to
get something and no one cares yeah
that's okay you ever rile anyone up
sometimes people get more caring more
now though I think your career is
getting bigger yeah it's been better now
last six months yeah you know I had to
really turn it up you know say Meghan
McCain [ __ ] her dad ID take it to the
next level oh yeah yeah and then people
were like oh okay
well listen it's incest we'll get people
to move yeah I had to say she had sex
with her father's corpse and then people
like oh okay but in here's the thing
about incest dude everybody's like ah no
no right yeah but what I'm thinking
about is you back in the day you didn't
have the only people who lived around
you were a kind of family or somebody
that was you know yeah close and you
didn't have everyone didn't have a
bicycle or like if you had a bicycle
then yeah maybe you'd [ __ ] somebody that
wasn't distantly related to you yeah but
if you didn't you could only have sex
well as far as you can walk or as far as
you could yeah you know see you would
people would have sex more local that
yeah you didn't have a choice I think
that still goes on I think that's still
probably happening oh yeah there's some
areas and stuff you going you're like oh
it's like I think people are using that
exact rationale to when they're in court
like listen I have sex as far as I walk
and then there's a judge gone okay
sounds great yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I only have one bike yeah I can't
get anywhere look I don't have a burr
yeah I got a skateboard but I just think
back in the day and then at a certain
point to like look you got to get some
exercise you're gonna have to gift a
wall not well not because of uber
because of birds like I don't want to
hear any excuses about you not being
able to travel you know five plus miles
I got Birds and limes
yeah there's lying around every corner
yeah you should be able to [ __ ] like you
know not your siblings yeah or not like
unless you
want to I feel like that's a whole
nuther
yeah that's a whole nother problem but
it shouldn't be transportation I would
never want to man I thought maybe my
sister was cute for like a six month
seem right but it's it you'll see yeah
decent matter like what age what a dream
we were kids yeah no she was like nine
and I think I was like 13 or something
but I didn't think she was like hot or
such oh that's a cute kid that lives in
our house you know right all right which
is good that's a but anyway what about
the so the fight so this is gonna be a
real suitable this fight go on to some
like W like like sanctioned card or what
does that happen yeah yeah yeah it's
it's legit man Eddie hurts promoting it
he's that he's the he's one of the
biggest boxing promoters in the world if
not the biggest it's gonna be on the
disown app mmm Daz in right shameless
plug his own app but yeah but it's gonna
be [ __ ] crazy got a little throw a
little one-to-one to action what for
action would it be different about this
fight than the first when he did and I
didn't see the first one I know it was
like I had a million streams I know that
a million to two million pirated every
way crazy like lost twenty million
dollars in one night twenty million plus
and why not crazy [ __ ] sucks dude
and were you getting paid on buys and
stuff or is that yeah we were getting
paid a biodome flat fee because we did
it through youtube right now disowned we
have that don't bought the fight they
want the rise to define the difference
this time is like yo last time I went in
as a youtuber who had to learn how to
box in like three or four months that's
boxing is hard boxing is not a sport you
can just walk into and rely on your
athleticism to make you do well which I
which I did right and I did okay but for
the hope the past year I've been
training like pretty rigorously yeah so
and so this time I'm actually like I
would consider myself a fully fed vetted
boxer
well you cuz your energy even felt
differently when you came in here and
when I went on impulsive oh yeah I was
it just seemed like you had I was like
oh wow this guy looks a little bit
leaner a little more you just seemed a
little bit like more of an athlete I
think in a way oh you got a serious
Center you weren't dude I thought you'd
be goofy er yes until you walk you're
like a goofy energy yo life a while -
sure like you went in and like look down
like rocky like you're ready
also boys I'm [ __ ] sick I am on the
cusp of death okay you know like yeah
I'm fine you sure cuz my face feels red
in my life like it but also yeah he's
dead yeah I've seen some real corpses
but you she looks good he seems fine you
wouldn't think he's sick I mean I think
I would I've seen you know I people I I
think you don't look sick yeah I think
you look like a guy who maybe right now
I think if you didn't sleep for a night
or two you'd look like a guy who is
probably doing a lot of drugs for all
what's the training regimen like what
are you doing every day I want to get
inspired I want good writing regimen
that okay are you working out by the way
or just well it's it's but you tell me
what working out is you working out is
and then I'll tell you what I'm doing
even using a CPAP yeah what do you mean
by working out if you mean going to the
doctor yes but no uh so what do you do
what's your regimen and I'll tell you my
regimen okay so ready I'm not doing that
I don't do that I don't believe in twice
a day but that's your way you want to do
it is fine it's a bit above average yeah
twice a day to me is a little much so
yeah you just took the lead yeah you
just took the lead but what about you I
see you guys yeah I want some training
this morning I'll just we'll see a
trainer now so three days a week and I
just hired a yoga trainer as well some
do that yeah a yoga trainer what the
what is that somebody motivates you to
do yoga basically a sculptor basically
but insane you get into a bad position
and they just sculpt you into a better
just a middle-aged lonely woman who's
like CEO time oh yeah it's time oh yeah
oh you haven't trained with the yogurt
trainer yet no no she's gonna come next
week so they're normally yoga
instructors yeah I've never heard of a
yoga trainer like a height woman to get
you really into it well dude if I flip
my dog well she gives me like a little
bacon or so you roll out of bed excited
to but no I go but I just don't do it as
much as I used to but I know that when I
do I feel better so I'm trying to get it
more into my life you meditate yeah
people around I got to start doing that
hey where you from again I'm from
Louisiana
what are your parents think about the
meditation uh my mother really believes
in it and my father's deceased so he
probably tries to contact me through it
I guess yeah
but I don't know or he still thinks it's
gay he probably still could you know
he's like I still don't support this new
when I was young a lot of stuff was
pretty gay bro even Jingle Bell what is
are you sitting on a dick Theo he's just
upset somewhere in heaven he wouldn't
think all a tad dude oh so what is it
well what is the regimen I wanna I want
to hear this you wake up yeah we wake up
we run we box how long do you hold on a
second hold on Jim who was we me and my
bro Oh your brother's sister brothers
right there with you the whole time
sometimes he wasn't he wasn't today but
most the time yeah
and is that did is that it just a
commitment you guys made is I think he's
gonna fight on the undercard I think
he's gonna find on the other undercard
and he enjoys boxing just like me like
you hired a yoga trainer and a personal
trainer right to me
boxing is just as effective workout wise
and it's a practical skill like I don't
I don't like picking up weights I
haven't picked up a way in two to three
years just like yeah you look good you
sculpt yourself you feel good but boxing
not only does all that happen but like
like but also you can be someone's eyes
I might have to attack someone who knows
sometimes a some you don't like you
might have to attack him it is a club or
a restaurant
I'll never attack I'll never - I'll
antagonize hey hey you know who whatever
happens happens you might a do it fail
to have okay so you might get traffic
you have a train or two or not I do yeah
okay yeah his name is Milton okay yeah
and so you guys go out with him and you
guys are doing guys hit the ring are you
hitting the ring under you have a boxing
ring at her locks ring in my backyard
yeah you seen I saw that so you're
hitting that every day every day
Wow so five mile run yeah yeah yeah yeah
we do about three three four right now
but we'll get up to the five mile what
two months out you know so if you if you
peak now we're [ __ ]
yeah you know right you gotta let you
gotta train and get the get the spurts
of yeah exerting yourself and are you
guys blowing a lot of gas each other
y'all talking a lot of [ __ ] you and the
other guy it just gotta do it it's just
gotten outside yesterday oh wow so we
hadn't we haven't really had a chance to
like to do it man I wish I could I wish
I could use your wit like I'm gonna I'm
gonna actually channel you Theo because
I feel like I'd be able to her a lot of
good insults just oh dude no it's not
like each other is it like one of those
things I hate the kid really
it's on and use a black kid from England
it's not why I hate them
no no no I know I'm not waiting I see it
now I see what you're doing yeah
so you're fighting for the white race
okay well what's his D he's he's like
the biggest YouTube guy in England right
yeah he's yeah oh yes yeah he's yeah
yeah okay I didn't know I'd never seen
him I know his name's kr1
that's right yeah no one no I mean I'm
gonna be honest if you're in America
like you don't know who the kid is if we
don't well here's the thing first of all
if we like if we wanted to be in Britain
so bad we'd have stayed over there say
we our ancestors here so bad it was
going we got into a boat left there
people like where you going we're like
we don't even [ __ ] know
leaving we're out that's imagine it
being you don't have enough gas to get
there you like yeah well [ __ ] yeah we'll
see what let's figure it out got this we
got this barrel of pepper that's what we
need we've got some spices and we're
good to go man this huggers are nuttier
so this is so this is uh was the first
bout hearing him in the US as well no it
wasn't it was a Manchester Oh now LA for
a better home from Yerevan and you got
it is what I'm saying you did yeah do
you feel like the first one it was a
draw it was a draw I was a tie man yeah
it sucked do you feel like it was a time
I feel like I wanted he looks like a guy
he looks a formidable opponent is his
picture behind me yeah I think so yeah
unless what the [ __ ] you I mean bro ks1
look at his face
first look how you how you gonna take
that serious yeah I would tell you I saw
him in an alley I would take it
seriously you know what I mean and
that's just because if I saw him in an
alley I would be somewhat threatened but
how many men have you met in alleys a
lot but it's usually just from out of
nowhere if I just saw those dreadlocks
it looks like a tarantula and dude I
think guys those logs don't have the
most dread in them I think this is the
number that looks is this look like
white girl dreadlocks doctor looks like
yeah to me that this is what that
pictures the photographer was like okay
now scrunch your face and look talk and
that's what happen I've seen tougher
black woman at a bus stop in Baltimore
yeah yeah absolutely next fight you just
fight black limit a bus stop in
Baltimore dude I saw this lady one time
sponsored by Popeyes new chick this lady
drinking a whole six-pack of baby
formula no yeah
there's gotta be some sort of
nutritional benefits that we don't know
about but that's great but by the way
that makes me think how good is formula
that's what I'm saying that's the other
thing is that just nice Nestle Quik
yes potentially for me so that's the guy
right there k every one man and was so
what do you feel like he's gonna be
training as hard as you do you feel yeah
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah man I'm not
gonna lie man's a dog yeah I'll give it
to him okay yeah man's got heart he
works hard I work it's it's sick it's
sick I want to fight somebody now do you
though because this [ __ ] is rigorous man
is violent yeah you know how many times
like this fine you get hit in the head
before you realize oh [ __ ] this is gonna
have some long-term repercussions oh wow
so you're saying you even noticed that
just from that fight I spell too
sometimes
yeah like oh you too I spell it some
yellow t wo how did you spell it
correctly t oo you to write like such a
to people like I noticed that my little
my text sometimes misspelled the word
and I'm like [ __ ] it's gotta be boxing
damn I'm 24 bro I'm Abbi I'm gonna come
back here in six years yeah I'm gonna be
in a wheelchair do you be wheelchair
racing like chant it's called
punch-drunk
I'll be punch-drunk yeah I don't want to
be in a wheelchair and they do have that
man yeah sometimes uh sometimes you see
some of these guys and they're not all
they're a little bit worse
wait so you're saying you really noticed
that just from from that one from that
bout I don't know what else who could be
from man I love I was in the spelling
bee like why am i misspelling simple
words well how far did you get into
spelling I was who limited the first
round okay so technically we were all in
this valley we had to do it you know
what this word I misspelled it was
kettle Oh give it a shot hi e TT le [ __ ]
you bro yeah I I say a no I said ETL oh
that's great well there's this kid yeah
it was this kid might in my grade still
rather
of your life but I did spell captain you
know what I mean I'd still rather leave
as you well that means anything shout
out to this girl brah named big Helina
do with this girl 5th grade spelling bee
I lost to a girl named big Helina who
honestly no I'm not joking him with
you're handsome but she looked just like
you bruh first of all she was pregnant
good for low and 5th no no at 10 100 %
pregnant did you grew up at the best
make checks as much as possible 100%
pregnant and I lost on the word
inconvenience and she won the [ __ ]
spelling because she knows all about it
and she knows all about and quit school
when you get to your uncle's baby in
sixth grade and Huffington wherever
Louisiana it's an inconvenience oh yes
she definitely said she had insider
trading I think when yeah yeah but
that's crazy though that she beat me I
remember losing him it hurt me a little
bit but I was a good speller too man
yeah yeah you said you like words on our
podcast yeah yeah see you love words
yeah how often you find yourself just
reading the good old dictionary I got
actually really cool rhyming dictionary
a friend of mine game oh he died but he
gave it to me like like a dictionary
that one rot word will rhyme with the
other word yeah it's like every word
that'll rhyme like that you know but it
was written about maybe 20 years ago so
they don't have like a lot of new words
in there we're not doing hip-hop no it's
not pretty pop just like making your
brain think like where you could connect
you know that you might not know that's
interesting yeah um so is there
something different you'll do for this
second fight I'm really curious about
this because it's uh yeah I just can't
imagine getting to a beef space income I
would love to see it though where it's
like their beefs are their real I know
they're abusive honesty do we have are
there like public beefs that ever get to
the level of I think Maniscalco and
Andrew Dice Clay yeah that was getting
wild yeah dice was taller that'd be cool
yeah that'd be cool it'd be great to see
that fight I'm trying to think I think
well I think more celebrities should
fight yeah like how cool is that
well that but I think it's all starting
to merge man it's all starting to come
together like you know it's like like
reality stars our presidents our
presidents yeah
reality stars are the number one pop
star in America World yeah she was on
you don't have hot be lovin if I mean no
disrespect to her at all but I'm just
saying it's like it's all it's all
murdered
one very somewhat scary thing yeah so
it's like you could be fighting Vladimir
Putin in four years I heard that man's a
dog yo you know he's right he rides
bears he does he does a lot of Cola he's
the biggest guy on YouTube in Russia
yeah
Vladimir Putin number one that's
unbelievable
so yeah so if it makes sense that you
guys went at it yeah who knows you know
you're like the top YouTube star in
every country
ooh like you go to Pakistan whoever it
is [ __ ] them just move on the next
person I want to [ __ ] I want to find
that Gregor dude do you I want to be
like I want to get my face [ __ ] by
McGregor I bet in two year you could be
him he's only getting older and his
whiskey's only getting shittier yeah and
I'm young spry and he also I think it
seemed like he might be on a little bit
of that dust you feeling yeah that's why
he's punching old men you see that yeah
yeah I'm just punching old Mennonite
everybody wants to [ __ ] hit an old
everybody wants to hit an elderly person
yeah I've always said that I think Irish
hello to a bunch in a senior citizen
because they're wise they think they're
not gonna get hit elderly people are
always popping off saying [ __ ] cuz you
can't hit making their teeth out of the
set in the moment yeah but they know
what they're doing if they need a sign
of disrespect I'm gonna take part of my
body off and set it on the table while
you're having a sandwich that's
disgusting they're asking for it yeah
yeah I just I just fear their egos there
maybe too big like their egos are like
what is what it was at 20 yeah no and
then they never escaped it and then
their body doesn't move as fast right
it's you know you're getting you're
getting hit in the head by an MMA but ya
honor it like if in if in a couple years
you'll have like if it's all just
starting to merge together like a you'll
be four you'll be you'll be fighting you
ever I love the idea of having YouTube
stars from around the globe fight each
other I think so today's deathmatch yeah
dude if Trump and Biden or the nominate
liked obviously Trump is but if Biden's
the nominee they have talked so much
[ __ ] about fighting each other and
they're gonna be oh I did see that yeah
so you wonder they're gonna be standing
at podiums
debating so could this be the first
[ __ ] presidential throwdown
y'all see um did you all see the Bernie
Sanders and Joe Rogan do you guys yeah
yeah I did
yeah dude how cool it was like the
greatest I mean it's just like you
learned so much about Bernie and like I
said in a heartbeat yeah I think it
changed it I think it really changed the
whole landscape of what podcast can be
now yeah that one interview for me I was
like holy [ __ ] Joe does that a lot
yeah but to do it I just never said I
don't know for some reason that one
really land really for me yeah yeah what
well yeah because Bernie's a guy that
you got to listen to for a while right
yeah and everybody usually is all right
they're just like just some flapjack
that's out there just right you know
slinging dope little one-liners yeah his
pulse interview was good to know whole
snap yeah Tulsa Gavin came on uh tells
he gathered from Hawaii
she was good you didn't like it not for
you they were not look man she's from
Hawaii so I don't think she should be
the president yeah I'll say look cuz why
he's a barbecue pit and we're not gonna
elect somebody who knows nothing about
the world I behold uphold the villas
hitting on Iraqis from Hawaii and he
talked about being the president that's
true but I don't with a college in Miami
you're living in Hawaii you're escaping
you don't know what to do with Detroit
yeah you know why you're watching
surfers all day yeah that's you know
yeah you don't know what the hell's
going on in Chicago you don't have a
clean look let's get a question came in
here right now from from someone let's
get this it's Kai Reed here in Rhode
Island and my question is for Theo and
it's after having both chris d'elia and
logan paul on the pod I know there's
some beef between the two what do you
think takes it in a fist fight
I think there's beef I think there's
probably you know soy chorizo no I think
I think you would beat him I think if
it's fist fighting I think that Logan
would win I think if it's tickling
somebody from far away with their feet
then Chris would win yeah he's lengthy
both worthwhile things bro he can
literally no joke from right here
[ __ ] put his foot out bro yeah and we
can play by saying dude yeah I wouldn't
give it to Chris oh I wouldn't give it
to Chris right away bro no endangered
species on the table it's a grizzly bear
was killed to make those teachers
two bears a mother and a father him and
Jake strangled the ball to death and
make those who come after me glass a
Gucci go after good shoe cheese fall
it's unbelievable the animals that they
must are you a Chris Kuehl now uh yeah
we are yeah we are yeah yeah we go I
would die that whole period of my life
was just like just pure [ __ ] like I
I've watched and footage of myself like
at that time when I remember the tweet
yeah and I tweeted at Chris and I was
like I was like now I know why your
comedy career is dying and he said like
at least when my career dies you can
film and put it on YouTube like like
Grand Slam broken yet he's really into
it what am i I'm a [ __ ]
yeah but I hold life like man I hated
myself did you guys I hate I hated
myself that look looking back now
looking back now at the time I was like
this is dope yeah I'm a YouTube star
yeah and now it's like oh just acting
out yeah I think so I think I was his
last I was pissed that everyone hated me
yeah you do the crazy prank yeah have
you ever done one of those were you
regretted it like a crazy prank
well obviously the one that we all know
about get the one in the forest yeah
right that one which I think was offence
I was like whatever you me as a person
who found it offensive no I mean me and
my friends played with dead people alive
people people over in the middle you
know why did you just couldn't get any
we couldn't monetize it were who were
from the generation that can't monetize
the sociopathy why I wish we know but
that wasn't that wasn't but have you
ever done something where you're like oh
I shouldn't uh yeah I poured gasoline on
my brother uh I tried to pour gasoline
on my brother he ran away and I slipped
in it and almost broke my shoulder yeah
see that I'm doing my boy Todd one time
at Halloween drank a [ __ ] half gallon
of gasoline dude and no joke we never
[ __ ] saw him again yeah that's what
never probably fine oh I think he's fine
but I think he I'm never gonna be fully
fine right you know interesting like I
think he can get a job and I don't think
he get like uh promoted
yeah he's not gonna get to the manager
of Perkins this dude he's gonna be he
ain't goin hard to do it or was he one
of those please been doing some
mushrooms dude and we [ __ ] hit the gas
station if you're on mushrooms and you
there's nowhere to go do you go to a gas
station bro in that place is [ __ ] like
that seems like the least appealing a
lazy on mushrooms
and they had a bunch of roaches a whole
[ __ ] swarm of roaches it just hit our
area and so there was like probably 600
roaches at this gas station I love that
in your area you take mushrooms but you
realize life is worse let's go to the
gas station where we're all gonna work
in three years
let's it's like what a nightmare let's
go to the beach and realize we're all
one consciousness now let's go to the
mobile and see where exactly we're
headed so see how many uh let's go to
rolls I can put my mouth a nightmare it
was amazing man Betty it was amazing but
he didn't see my kind of guy was gonna
do super great overall anyway you just
shows in this podcast so far you've
mentioned three friends that have kind
of just disappeared
why is that a thing in Louisiana like
where your friends going it's easy place
I mean it's a places a lot of you know
I'm called Minh sacks yeah it's not what
a lot of brother going into the ether
man the part of the mystery yeah off the
face of the earth it is a place that has
uh just a lot of mystery they all become
Netflix documentaries yeah do what do
you think what did you ask him a second
ago there was something I wanted to talk
more about that it was a good question
forgot
yeah who's talking about Chris D'Elia
beef oh yeah Chris D'Elia beef do you uh
yeah
but crystal II I think is more of an
online beef person than he is a real
human in life beef he's a nice guy so
yeah yeah I feel I'd like to believe
that most people are I mean I can't I
don't know how many people I got I got
real beef with other than that one kid
right you know the British guy yeah the
British guy yeah I mean what does that
come from that beef is that she's
talking [ __ ] you guys are both online
yeah so it was it started off cool and
then it during the press conferences and
[ __ ] just he crossed the line I crossed
the line and it just got super toxic and
unhealthy and now here we are we want to
[ __ ] rip each other's heads off and
it okay it's all this kind of healthy
man you know like yeah one of my friends
is fighting this weekend in the
but which one in the UFC Poirier against
khabib the eagle oh [ __ ] you like the
boy might get rocked dude yeah but he's
a diamond bruh so you know he already is
I think legally Iraq but but yeah I mean
anybody could win you know they got a
fight right
I mean khabib is a rare specimen no he's
not even a human it's really crazy
watching him it's almost like watching
one of those things that they put into a
scary movie that just goes up as him
yeah and his arms go behind like this
it's very very cross battle he can put
bro he [ __ ] can put but he can take
his arms off dude and swallow them and
[ __ ] almost terrifying yeah yeah
terrifying dude he's uh but anyway but
yeah you see these guys like yeah I'm
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of that guy and
it's like it's playful but it's also
like this is what we're doing now do you
feel like this is so this is something
you're doing now as far as like fighting
people I think so man I mean yeah are
you gonna do you think you're gonna
continue this I think so
Wow I think it's just do you think you
become a boxer like a legend ah I'm
gonna do MMA I've wrestled in high
school I was good I placed a 5th in Ohio
so like I surround so that a lot of that
is there yeah right yeah it boxing is a
little limiting for many of the other
YouTube guys your social media guys
doing stuff like this no and I'll tell
you why
well they're [ __ ] no nope there are a
hundred times smarter than me yo think
about it I mean [ __ ] combat sports are
dangerous they are this is not healthy
getting hit in the head over and over
again right what am i some kind of [ __ ]
the answer's yes
like I'd like to believe that everyone
else is it's a combination of their
they're smarter and it's not worth it
and they probably don't want to work
that hard because that's hard work right
right
you know I got like something's some
screws are missing it's for it's not
just beating somebody up is a legit
sport yeah we have to Train yeah and
you're gonna lose like um do you feel
like you're gonna kind of create a new
fan base with some of this tool oh for
sure for sure that's why stuff will
change yeah that's why I do I noticed in
the last fight the last fight after we
did it I was instantly elevated from
YouTube star to like whatever the the
level right right below like traditional
celebrity and YouTube star like
whatever's in between that is this
you know your boldface name people know
you oh yeah yeah yeah you know you walk
in somewhere it sound like oh that's the
guy that makes YouTube videos like oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ] knows how to
fight and it's a different level of
respect and the [ __ ] game is huge I love
fighting my new UFC forever
the chuja oh yeah yeah man it's huge and
it's growing and it's like what's gonna
be next like and this could be it you
know seeing people actually get to you
know talk [ __ ] but also back it up if
they want to in the rain maybe man cuz
the online [ __ ] talking is there's never
really been a place for Coleman nobody
goes and organizes a fight between Rosie
O'Donnell and post POW they should be
fighting each other
someone's gonna do it a hundred percent
when you say like looking back on
yourself like and you can watch like
videos when you're younger it's kind of
crazy that most people don't have that
experience though it's like you're like
one of the few people that can have that
experience cuz so much of you is
documented oh so then it's so much so
much of who I was right well it's
pretending to be at the time yeah but we
all were it's like that's just a phase a
lot of us go do like but then did you
did you like when you look back at
footage from like five years ago do you
feel like you were a lesser version of
yourself or oh yeah and I loved it dude
okay I love being a lesser version
myself I've had to be like more you know
you got to get do stuff got a call Nick
you know you got to do all kinds of
stuff now it's more responsibility I
feel you so I like the lesser version
when I didn't have to do that much yeah
but I but that's also me a little bit
older like if I'm looking back on my
teen years and stuff dude [ __ ] knows
we'll be on there bro
yeah crazy position yeah brah anything
involving fire uh that you can legally
discuss do we used to do this thing for
Japan where girls were putting it out
LSD and their vagina dude yeah and how'd
that work out this was a fun school this
high school people are pregnant is a
real interesting cropping care dude you
got no heart people are drinking
gasoline you gas in the vagina
you got no like problems I didn't even
know
could be problems like I didn't even
know these things could ask the Marikana
I have a [ __ ] and it was an old school
thing but I think it's coming back bring
it back bring it back is it you get
[ __ ] up faster yeah I mean you get
[ __ ] up almost four you can even open
your mouth and close it back interesting
that's quick that's the way think about
that and put it in and then wow that's
quick bro the chip and who named it
that's fast act vagina trippin yeah a
couple of these broads that went hard
let's go for chip and then what was that
[ __ ] boxing when you call a [ __ ] fighting
it was first of all it was just above
the ear people who brought the business
a tail we gotta make money I agree
people gotta make my fear gay in
Louisiana in rural Louisiana you're
gonna have to beat the [ __ ] out of
another gay guy you know designing
houses you're not an interior designer
you're gonna have to fight and you hope
that some fans come in whoever chip in
rob some FedEx it all for jimping who
think it's great [ __ ] bet $100 on his
duty Enrique what time's break [ __ ]
guy I love that's how you it's amazing
beautiful small guy did you treat
Enrique lose loss bro but it was all
kind of stirred up but I don't know was
it yeah I was at the age where it was
all a show I didn't realize this was
like professional wrestling this was all
choreographed yes it was all
choreographed this is poured gay dudes
you couldn't become dancers what to just
beat the [ __ ] out of each other in
Louisiana
no it was kind of like I mean it was
like you could you could you could
probably promote it one day yeah there
should be about that and yeah bro a big
Gator a gay traveling circuit bro their
house - dude you could get you should be
able to wrestle with a bear at AA bar
you used to be able to do that
everywhere where that had the had bears
yeah you can't do that now you can't do
that now it's dangerous yeah yeah but it
was just like people were going to a bar
and wrestle a bear you got to give him
here to pay $10 and then you could just
wrestle a bear
you could wrestle him for a little bit
in New York City it was really rich kind
the lady can hunt he kept the bear
chained to a stake in his lawn because
that was a way to show everyone he was
really rich I liked that he had a bear
that's gangster and it's not a big bear
chain it was steak just but the thing
would hang out on the lawn and people
would be like that guy's no true there's
not a better way to flex you think
there's not a better way to flex it just
having a bear like that
yeah I still think I still think that's
something you should consider you bet it
all in the law have the nice car the
house gives a [ __ ] Russell the bear to
get up there get a grizzly artist
hanging or grisi although I have I have
a mastiff Tibetan Mastiff those are
great you have a Tibetan masters biting
people though well they're vicious
animals I didn't know yeah I mean
they're vicious
I think it's sexy when a dog bites
somebody I like to watch someone get bit
- a little bit look I hate to interrupt
this episode for for for this
advertisement but I got to pay the rent
it's a new season Antonio Brown is on
the Raiders and his ego is playing about
nine different positions for them right
now
Le'Veon bells with the Jets Odell
Beckham jr. is in Cleveland
things are changing the one thing that
hasn't changed is where I put my money
down on all the games my bookie is the
place to bet on football every weekend
my bookie has better bonuses more prop
bets than any other sports book this
year my bookie is hosting the first
online handicapping super contest first
place is guaranteed to win at least a
hundred thousand and it only costs $100
to enter all you gotta do pick five NFL
games against the spread every week to
climb the leaderboard and score your
share of the huge cash prize pool my
bookie also has live in game betting on
every NFL game listeners get up to
$1,000 first deposit bonus that's right
you can double your first deposit put in
a thousand $1,000 bonus
use promo code PA st to activate the
offer visit my bookie online today
that's my B ooki e and don't forget to
use the promo code pas t when creating
your account to claim the bonus bet win
get paid my bookie dot-com promo code
past today's up but yeah it's just crazy
you can look back on your life like
nobody else has that same thing where
they have to look back because then
you're just more likely to judge
yourself dude if 22 year old me showed
up right now bro what what I think you
know
be like damn dude tighten up dude for
hell yeah I think so yeah what do you
think you think you're too loose I just
don't know I just don't know what am i
open huh I don't know what I would think
yeah what did you guys think about the
um the Justin Bieber post you see is
post about the Tom Cruise about the no
not Tom wants to fight well he wanted to
play some fruits
talk about the mental health one well
yeah but first let's talk about Tom
Cruise then that would be a good fighter
in that same card that would be a good
fight Cruz Bieber I think I may not
think I'd be I think Bieber would wipe
the floor with them if I'd be an honest
man I mean I think so too
Tom he's just - all dude too old to get
that old man strength though and science
bro if you got Scientology dude you
could do anything you want you could do
magical most yeah I don't know about
that they're whole things based on
blackmailing gay dude I think that's
what it's really going here's a picture
you kissing a dude what's that cost 25
grand a month for the rest of your life
okay cool whatever I'm Batman or
whatever it is I think that's what it is
I don't think it's magic I feel like
Logan gets nervous every time Tim brings
up gay people but he is gay so he's a
lot to tell ya I'm allowed to everything
I want I can say the n-word Oh say I'm
kidding I can't say the n-word I can say
I'm John I don't they look at this gay
way are you gay yeah yeah oh well I can
say okay oh he's very nervous no I mean
controversy what would you do man this
goes [ __ ] don't worry about it well we
are [ __ ] them and it's not going that
way because they always go to the they
always find something homophobic that
like a violent you didn't hear this I
don't not I didn't hear what happened
he's like I killed three gay guys I hate
to bring it up right now in Ohio me Jake
it was funny in a time every gay guys
and light him on fire
sorry he said you didn't hear this it
was a guy named Matthew Shepard and it
was the first viral video we tied him to
him anyway
no I'm what do you say no no dude I said
we were God we were gonna hook up with
dudes in March male only March you've
got it and I used I used the verbage
I said we were gonna go gay right okay
that's funny and upon an on our podcast
right it's the verbage I use and instead
of saying yell we're gonna hook up with
dudes from March is my mail only March
as a joke did we did sober vegan January
fatal February we're gonna the joke was
we're gonna do male only Marcin yeah I
just it was I just an out-of-touch joke
you know I mad yeah people got mad
online people did online people I mean
nobody in the real world cares and
that's the truth that's the thing is the
online thing and there's a real what
they did it effect you think the
long-term way that people are
interacting with you me yeah yeah like
nobody said liven turned around me were
like you hear about that [ __ ] mail
only March they're gonna go gay that's
ridiculous yeah nobody nobody's cares
that's the crazy thing it's people just
trying to get their kids medicine yeah
that's really the real world
roll in LA nobody cares people just want
to give their kids medicine when they're
sick that's literally what people are
worried about nobody I don't know if I
go gay for a whole month bruh do not do
a week first you guys seem brave month
is a lot yeah it's heavy is there would
you do straight for a month you think
yeah so I would do straight for a
decent-size starter house yeah for the
rest of my life like not even like a
meal two little mediterranean-style on a
busy corner doesn't even have to be no
backyard partially rent it out yeah I
mean listen it sound like yeah I would
try it for months I mean I've tried it
before I tried it a bunch it didn't work
oh really yeah yeah cuz you know I
remember one time I thought I was maybe
gay for a little while but I was just
really lonely I think and I just been
masturbating too much yeah and attracted
to yourself essentially is that were
saying I don't know what was going on
nude but it was just like I don't know
dude oh I wasn't meeting any girls and I
was like oh [ __ ] man if I'm not meeting
any girls maybe I'm gay and I'm just
don't know what's going on yeah right so
never shut it off never like who knows
oh no yeah what I'm seven you're 80 due
to her search yeah ditto for everybody
in here yeah sure I'll [ __ ] in you
creeps that's it that's it that's a
Richard Nixon right there right
but yeah who knows dude I mean who know
but yo also like okay I'll just say like
I've kissed dudes before yeah I mean it
was an acting class you know not like it
was on recreational yeah but like I it
was not nothing against remember the
guys name or not
Oh Sean feel like it was Tyler oh yeah
no use it by the beach dude I would
never kiss from am aw the big guy
I know exactly you're talking about wait
Tyler he's a famous actor no he's not oh
he's not I know another Tyler that's
okay that's Tyler and it's him right did
you go there yeah I do I used to be in
Tony's class for life so that's I'm
saying you do you do scene oh yeah
sometimes you can hand it a guy on guy
seen it like let's be honest like I'm
not a [ __ ] [ __ ] relax I know you got
excited when I said I [ __ ] got any
arms falling can I join the class so I
want to be I wanna be I wanna be Power
yeah how can I be in power well we [ __ ]
if I'm in power how does it work can I
be a prison guard I don't even know what
powers about about prison right no all
right so is Tyler just milling around
these classes waiting for the scene he
did it to Jionni
no no no he has a girlfriend - yeah and
in any acting or movie like I've kissed
dudes in in movies up here - like yo
this is the way it is work the way
Hollywood some do kissed some dude
actually ejaculated on my arm when I was
a Tom what class was that no it wasn't a
class I was in a movie theater very hot
it hot so what happened then his
girlfriend him a [ __ ] and I was too
close to them to him well you know Louie
Z Anna - that's why yeah I'm gonna die
kind of by the interstate a little bit
yeah here by the interstate
yeah that's what a good snow you wanna
know dude 200 yards off the [ __ ]
interstate and you're in a film bro
would you remember your name a better
time remember the movie huh yeah I
remembered it's called Pumpkinhead it
was a scary movie those are the best
movies to get hand jobs in though bro I
wasn't getting it dude I was a [ __ ]
victim no I know but the guy heat like
he clearly he knew something
Oh what did you do after you just got
come down in the movie I didn't know
what was going on did I thought I was
gay for about two months
yeah interesting because you have to it
that age some
comes on you in a theater makes you
think I'll just make it scared I thought
you liked was I chosen is this the way
it happens this way they were I think I
have a choice can I look at a woman now
I have to explain to her what happened
oh the tough [ __ ] yes she affected me
bro do you ever you how often you go
back to your hometown now I'll go back a
lot man yeah I'll go back a lot I was
just on the coast I was in Biloxi this
weekend doing a show yeah and everybody
did that stardome that I saw you were at
yeah / - yeah yeah it was wild that's
why did you ever do a tour did you know
I want to I wanted is it crazy
oh yeah it's crazy I mean with stand up
it's like I feel like it'd be tougher
for you for guys that are you know kind
of YouTube stars I don't know what the
best term is but with boxing on me you
could go and so and you could fight yeah
but I'm just saying with YouTube I think
it's different or you know I mean at
least I have a thing to do I would say
what the [ __ ] do I do
yeah you a yes no watch the thing
chasing Cameron on Netflix where they
they like would he do all that nobody
wants all those vine stars who go out
like they would like throw water bottles
and crap that's what they did why kids I
did see that actually yeah they jumped
around like sing two songs yeah throw
water in the crowd so me personally
probably rather die then yeah and do
that yeah looks good I'll make a cash
grab kana um what about the yeah the
Bieber posted what do you think about
that talk about the mental health one
yeah that was dope man anytime celebrity
opens up about Ronald Honorable [ __ ]
like it's cool yeah you know and in
pretty cool I thought yeah it's cool a
lot of a lot of people relate to it and
so when an icon can be open you know and
truthful about himself
yeah it's cool yeah 100% pretty wild to
think yeah I just couldn't imagine you
know it shows people you could have all
this stuff you can have all the money
you could have all the fame you could be
very talented you could still not be
happy you could still have a lot of
those problems yeah you know helps me
perspective real like person like it
whatever I'm having just a [ __ ] day and
I'm like one of the war you know sued
for like hundreds of thousands of
dollars like hurt myself in boxing in
the morning and it's like sick and I'm
just like [ __ ] nothing's going right I'm
always like someone someone somewhere
has it
so much worse yeah you know lots of
people have you know so like right here
so entire hemispheres haven't worked I
know you're like someone like he wakes
up wherever he is a Beverly Hills he's
like there's got to be someone out there
who's having a bad day today like I'm
having a bad day brother got some other
person out here let's see let's go to a
guy right here we got a guy right here
who is having a worse guy driving a
prison bus let's go to Michael guys hey
just wondering you know what the level
of success that you guys have is it
close I can smell the roses sometimes
would be actually proud of what you've
done and you know be really grateful and
happy with where you're at what do you
think it's like always gonna be a
constant battle of wanting the next best
thing and not really taking the time to
really think about how cool it is to be
in the position in your app feels like
sometimes a constant battle of always
wanting the next thing but yeah we'd
love to know guys thanks gang gang gang
Brooke that's a great question man
that's a great question um you always
want to do more stuff right well I think
that that is something that happens to
people I think there are certain types
of people that you there's a drive to I
don't know if it's success or
achievement or conquering the next thing
where it's just the thing in your brain
that turns over where it's like okay
what next do I try and accomplish right
and it's never changed you happen to
accomplish things along the way right
but it's what do what am I going to do
next yeah what gets you excited that's
what I feel it's like whatever excites
you like you're excited by this fight
yeah you wanted this yeah you're into
right now yeah whatever you're into it
might not be what you're into in six
months or a year but then you got to go
find that thing yeah and then keep
getting excited but your brain also I
think some people's brains some people
the way they are is going to find that
no matter what it's like yeah it's just
in you to find whatever that thing is
it's the same reason why you found
whatever the first thing was that kind
of got you going I would say fear that
keeps you from that right I think a lot
of people want to do things they don't
do them they're afraid or
of doing them but their circumstances
prevent them from doing them but I think
if you get rid of the fear of life maybe
I'll fail at that or maybe that's not
gonna be what I think it's gonna be if
you get rid of that fear then you just
open to what is the next thing what is
the next thing yeah it is hard to look
back I think it's definitely hard to
like stop and kind of smell the roses
kind of oh I make myself sometimes like
I'll force myself to go on vacation or
like I take Sundays off now no matter
what Wow cuz otherwise it's just you get
you caught up in the cycle of just
trying to go go go go go and then you
[ __ ] yourself you shoot yourself in the
foot oh yeah but no heater [ __ ] as
I'm saying artyom too much yoga yeah you
gotta chill
but no yeah I'm tryna it can burn I feel
like definitely burnout is a real thing
but a lot a lot of successful people
that I know weren't chasing the thing
that they have now they were they they
loved what they did and then they get
the win and that's where their dopamine
spike comes in and that makes them happy
that's what excites them and then you
know it gets old on to the next what
else can I do what else can i conquer so
I think it's just you got to find that
that thing that makes you happy and then
it's like a compound effect if you keep
going and going and going next thing you
know you have all this success but this
success didn't call it didn't come
overnight you brandish it for you know
two 15 [ __ ] years yeah as all of us
have and there's a price for I mean his
success is really used you're starting
to get more popular yeah say that yeah a
little bit yeah yeah it started to over
the last year has been a good it's been
a good year do call me like eight and a
half nine years last year's been really
good and what do you kind of attribute
that to I think just have an opportunity
more people knowing about you coming out
here more I was in New York and I love
New York but coming out here meeting
more people you know getting the chance
to go and do different things and then
just being funny so getting a chance at
being funny getting funny and then going
and getting a chance to be funny in
front of people like Bert Kreischer is
like if you just build houses in a
neighbourhood and nobody sees them but
then you get a chance at building a
house a neighborhood and people are
looking at it and they're like oh I like
that
I won't build my house so I think that's
what it is yeah they're sticking with
something and then till it matters yeah
once people see that you can do yet
sometimes it comes too early for people
too it's like yeah you haven't really
you don't really have your art down and
then you get an opportunity and yeah
and then everybody sees your art as not
I mean we know a ton of dudes in
audition for SNL when they were 19 or
they had a huge opportunity with new
super young and or they got an
opportunity and it just didn't work they
were on a hot show for a year or
whatever and you know now those people
you know live in their cars and they're
suicidal and you know it's all over for
that you know but they're good to call
and be like God I'm not damn huh you
know that that's important to keep
somewhere someone somewhere keep them in
your phone a hot you're around you're
still alive all right well when I first
moved here so me and my buddy Paul we
didn't have an apartment yet so we
something the ball hit on my head the
McDonald's ball pin oh sure yeah we came
here at night you're lying
no we jump in there at night so get in
the ball pit cause it was safe that was
the biggest thing we tried to stay in a
park was it though was it safer that was
like the lowest level of Jeffrey
Epstein's island sleeping in a McDonald
it's like the poorest pedophile move
Robert here sleep in the ball pit you
know we take a public bus there the
third night run me and my buddy Paul are
in there just leaning you would get like
under the balls the worst part was
there's like a lot of hair and loose
change of course you're dead serious
right net serious this is amazing and
the third night we're in there we're
talking just like we had in the past
unite some Asian guy is sleeping on the
slide right down let me ask you a
question did was there no security or
emanation did no one in the McDonald's
care it was shut down there how did you
get in this one closed oh you jump right
over the fence and you're in the ball
and you're in the play arrow out to a
ball pit yeah indoors you fun after ball
pit in my life yeah and also how the
[ __ ] is that safe you a couple of
Rothschilds huh never seen what cuz
you're first of all you're in a place
you know one's going in there at what
point did you say to yourself this is
not a sustainable course of act like at
what point when you're under when you're
under the balls and you're sleeping in
some hair of heat whatever now you keep
your head out of the balls that's a real
moment that's a real moment ago like one
of those moms for me I was Santa Claus
in like Harlem and I was getting [ __ ] on
all day by like four year old kids and
you can say black
yeah they were there well some of them
are Dominican but we're just roasting me
just shamelessly be none of them are
happy to see Santa he's a hardened
little kid like [ __ ] you you fat [ __ ]
I'm like I'm Santa you know and I would
ring the jingle the bell and then every
now and then some drunk would like to
answer me and I was like this is a rough
I hope comedy works out he came out so
that had to be the ballpit moment when
you hear a heads out of the balls you're
like god I hope this works out I just
hated the fact that we were I just
didn't like those a traffic it was right
on Wilshire so it was like a lot of
traffic that was the biggest problem
with the traffic I was still yellow yeah
I was younger so I could handle the
pressure of it but it was just wasn't my
favorite thing but um [ __ ] were we
talking about dude
and everything since you slept in a ball
pit it's gonna been erased from my mind
oh speaking of Asians probably got a
[ __ ] Asian writing let's hear this
beautiful Viet hey what's up guys so my
question is for both you guys so if you
guys have a chance to have an interview
or a podcast with anyone dead or alive
who would that be
[ __ ] man that question always sucks I
feel like no offense man sorry yeah very
basic [ __ ] Oh Abraham Lincoln oh you
know Wesley Snipes yeah um you know
somebody else I would say either in both
of them either Christopher Hitchens or
Patrice O'Neal I would say Prince or
[ __ ] in I would say actually probably
Michael Jackson or Michael Landon what
would you owed you talked to Michael
about I would go in on real hard about
just seeing you know what
you know what what is sexual preferences
were probably trying to really just chat
about it and what about Michael Landon
that's where I'm more I'm more perplexed
about that I love Michael a name okay
interesting
I do Nikola Tesla oh wow I mean dude I
don't even do you know enough to even
interview a guy like that I wouldn't
even
it's very Thomas do I know about Tesla
coils you know are you gonna bring
Nikola Tesla back you like dude the cars
dope I would be like hey no I wouldn't
know what to say yeah hey won't you
fight Elon Musk on the under
yeah oh that's a nice that's all you
know what they said he died a virgin I
think I'd probably just ask him straight
up if you like needed some some things
but virgin power is so strong oh dude
that's crazy oh hey uh somebody parked a
Volkswagen Rabbit on this guy's leg one
time outside of our schoolhouse and I
saw a virgin [ __ ] lift it right off
his leg
why of yo and this was an [ __ ] who
knows what every scene is from like the
movie powder about every scene of your
lines like that I've never seen a virgin
pick up a car yeah
they pick up ak-47 virgins now are
picking up ar-15s hopefully they start
picking up cars again that would be nice
they need some [ __ ] then bro I agree
with you cuz they're shutting down all
the [ __ ] bro that's who's doing it
that's right we got a version right here
let's hear this young woman this is the
farthest thing from a basic [ __ ]
question what's up to you this questions
for all three you guys you can't leave
the room until you form a human
centipede what's the order gonna be
website do you want hey these are our
fans yeah these are people coming in
from my 8chan Scots it's for can now
good right they took four oh uh oh
you're eating cleanest salt would
probably say you up top yeah hey tight
you're up front I got to go in the back
because I have the least amount of going
on in my career Esther you're the
caboose dude
yeah I've thought least about going on
my manager be like you're lucky to be
there who's ever ass they tell you to
eat don't start any problems you don't
eat in the ass bro you just be there as
a receptacle right but don't get sexual
were there to [ __ ] survive do you
know what I try to get out of the room
it's like an escape room this guy he
works at the mall the middle-class guy
works at the mall what do you think even
come up with a question I said at the
mall all day smelling churros thinking
about what to ask the middle person dies
quick though do I think guys that I'll
sacrifice myself just to get out of the
[ __ ] situation did you see that movie
I never saw that
Oh cuz they're there why cuz they're
wait one of them dies quick just like
you know like biology Oh interested
yeah yeah a lot of you see I bother I
saw the movie did you I didn't see them
ah yeah
is it brutal great flick I want to watch
let's watch I wanna watch it now but
like tonight it's very flick go to our
own respective places back to our
Neutral corners I'm not saying let's
just watch a movie for two hours right
or neutral corners yeah that's crazy man
hey guys this is the last interruption I
promise but I got a I got a sweeten the
deal for you and I'm talking about honey
nine times out of ten shopping online
beats going to the store it's true you
go to the store who knows what could
happen you might fall down oh what's
happening here the lettuce is bad where
are all the televisions I want so online
you know what you want you get it they
bring it to you you at home you were
already ready to enjoy it nine out of
ten times though you're overpaying
online for whatever you're buying that's
why you need honey honey is a free
browser extension that saves you money
everywhere you shop online that's right
you just download honey on your computer
it's there when you're right before
you're buying something honey lets you
know if there's a better place I had a
better rate to get the same item honey
finds coupon codes and other discounts
across the web and applies them
automatically I don't know how it works
but honey saves me money where I already
shop places I've been shopping forever
suddenly I'm saving money now what I
bought using honey I'll tell you exactly
what I bought a set of skis so that's
good it's a lot it's a lot it's a great
question it's a great question from a
smart guy I called him a woman before
yeah what have you did he looks he looks
that guy has that look at people don't
want to be mas some people actually did
a lot of guys just want to be men there
the best man in their relationship what
is it man
huh like what's a man I think a man is a
guy that's trying to just look nice when
he leaves the house and do this he was
handed the hand send it up senators do
his best he can't he can't if he has it
in his truck and if he doesn't have a
truck he's not a man
I gotta have a truck that's saying that
dude but I think it helps you can't be
on a [ __ ] bird scooter on either side
of the wonder-percent yeah I agree with
you you gotta have a cool job you can't
be like a teacher or something dumb no
you could have a man teacher but you got
a [ __ ] dress still like a man it
weren't a lie agree with you okay if you
work alone around children dude you're a
[ __ ] man who the guy if you walk
through that hallway it just suffocates
people York along and the kids are like
[ __ ] a Spanish teacher and everybody
knows it yeah I agree
I'm agree did you guys ever have any
teachers hit on you even after you out
of school
especially probably with your success to
get my teachers that kind of reached out
huh I had it I hit on the teachers that
was that was risky though cuz were you
successful and in high school at the
same time oh no I was like a good
football player right no star kind I
kind of semi got the pass so I could
like say some things like oh like you
look I like your hair today yeah and she
was like yeah take your seat and I'd be
like all right go we know what's up yeah
we know it's happen but yo I mean who
doesn't have that weird fetish where
it's like I would love to hook up with
it one of my teachers I go my biology
teacher smoke show yeah she was bad so I
did cocaine with a substitute and that's
all that's as far as I got which is how
old are you I was maybe 18 maybe like
the year I graduated high school we're
doing coke with the sub one of our
substitutes and was he a homosexual or
she no as a channel woman yeah she was
just sub subs of the end what class she
was an English sob South she was an
idiot
yeah
so she wasn't smart she was probably
trying to go out and sniff some coke and
you know [ __ ] her way into the lower
middle class
she's [ __ ] away know a little Levitt
house in Long Island good woman oh you
got a place an tomorrow off today I
would love to watch the smalls like it's
a roasted me they were brutal and here's
the other thing I wasn't just saying I
was telling Obamacare because the thing
was he was a health care truck Oh Sam
has got a [ __ ] game he would have to
like get them with it they'd be like oh
there's Santa and then you get the kids
in then you grab their parents he'd be
like that's called a bait and switch a
bait and switch big time then you grab
their parents be like listen you're
gonna have a high deductible but it
doesn't matter just declare bankruptcy
you don't have to give him a fake name
anymore you know and you'd have to
explain to the kids you know like this
is this is a present that you're not
gonna realize the importance of now yeah
so it was it was a dark time I had fun
with it though you have fun with that
was younger I was doing comedy my life
shitty your life's been a real piece of
[ __ ] it's been it's been something okay
you know I never slept in a ball pit but
I'm not against it like I'm not opposed
to sleep but still yeah they were right
they were brutal little kids yeah oh I
could see that weed I was in Vietnam
once I'm gonna let a couple of kids cut
my hair right I thought it'd be like a
fun thing to do something different for
them yeah and this one [ __ ] [ __ ]
kid bro instead of trying to make it
look nice just [ __ ] yeah they're
demon little kids yeah so that hit me
hard
Nicholas throw a topic out there you got
a couple topics man and we'll get
through this yeah let's see
Prince Harry responded to criticism he
took a private plane four times in 11
days with his family and people took
umbrage with it because he's considering
an ambassador for climate change
awareness he responded back said I came
here by commercial I spent 99 percent of
my life traveling the world by
commercial occasionally there needs to
be an opportunity based on a unique
circumstance to ensure my family are
safe and it's genuinely as simple as
that I mean I think your Prince Harry
man you could do whatever you want to
thank while you're still a prince the
acid or for climate change awareness
even mean I don't know what that means
somebody that's hoping it's actually
really you show up something might show
up somewhere and you're like by the way
we got a
you know we gotta get these glaciers
back in order get out of there what do
you do to be honest the the article said
ambassador for climate change which
sounds like you're trying to make
climate change happen so I added the
this is a thing that people elites have
to do now that they have no interest in
like if somebody goes to him and goes
you got to get out your dude the planet
is falling apart you got it you're the
ambassador for climate right look at
these six seagulls I got on my phone
yeah go over there take a few pictures
in Greenland and you know let everybody
know we're doing the right thing you
know it's crazy how about poor people
too you know plus Michigan they're
hoping for a little climate change yeah
tell me I get eight extra degrees in a
winter [ __ ] yeah I can sign me up
dude like a penguin bro who cares
yeah I want to be able to go outside in
the yard on Christmas like that's the
thing climate change is gonna it's
definitely gonna really hurt probably
Millions right it's also going to and I
help the 48 thousand people that live in
Mission it's gonna restructure the value
of real estate around the Great Lakes so
suddenly the people that have all the in
inland real estate they're people like
all you live in a [ __ ] man you know
everything's gonna move cuz Manhattan
into Miami or underwater yeah frozen or
underwater you're [ __ ] now it's locked
right yeah look how rich you are yeah
swim they're buying them I got a lot of
other people buying stuff in Montana
right now yeah huge so I'm just saying
it's good what goes around comes around
you you can't win them all so it's like
you know you get ice some time you don't
that's the way that's that's probably
our official policy on climate change
now with Trump I think Trump would be
like sometimes you get ice sometimes the
next question but first of all then you
have [ __ ] like the Ice Age those [ __ ]
little animals are having a blast did
you see that it's a fun as hell they
made a second yeah everyone's fine
[ __ ] bad was it bad good a big yeah
it's a big snow day for a whole age yeah
give us Denis Leary ajob
yeah no much it um I love a change is
keeping a lot of [ __ ] people in
business not whether you did or non
climate change I don't even know which
is which anymore what else we got man
over the weekend the Boston straight
straight Pride Parade actually happened
about 200 people marched and 600
protesters showed up
three dozen people were arrested on
various charges including disorderly
conduct this is just fun people need
something to do people need stuff to do
yeah people get mad at these skirmishes
and Portland stuff
people need to dress up and beat each
other up with the times and shields this
is what it is not everybody's gonna
build a business or have a family okay
some people need to just let it out let
it out I love it is what it is I'm not
even I mean just that fun televise it
yeah she's right right all the beat yeah
like a sick pay-per-view yeah and by the
way this is what I would be doing like
I'd be I'd be fighting people in the
streets
yeah like LARPing like like real LARPing
that's what that's not be doing if I
wasn't doing this right there's nothing
to do in Ohio oh you got more to do than
LARPing fight people you have a car
dealership in Columbus Ohio be honest
was started at an Akron dude that's you
this [ __ ] to do there's the rock on the
range music festival where all those
families go vape together and watch
machine gun cab and you know yellow wolf
has a lot going on you can't your hell
that's true yeah yeah yeah we love Him
yeah we watched him in GK it was great I
watched I did comedy there no one wanted
that really they didn't want that it's
well I mean it's nobody's there for that
I mean we were in a tent we're in like
the comedy tent uh and then MGK and
those guys were the other thing we
didn't even want to do are well I can we
just go watch yeah the show and
obviously we had to we were a tent for
people that were like coming like they
would go vomit in the port-a-potty and
then come back to our tent to just get
their bearings okay and then go back you
would like a ancillary yeah to get back
to the main show so it wasn't it wasn't
my best let's say after because we're
almost like a bathroom we were
absolutely a bathroom yeah and I would
do it this year but it was a fun the
concert was great
yeah um straight proper eight I don't
know if I really is why this straight
people marching like I think well I
definitely think that straight men feel
kind of attacked I think there's a lot
of times I feel really attacked probably
especially my like the news and stuff
like that like if you're straight white
if you're a straight white Christian man
you're definitely you're a complete
piece of [ __ ] you have no value anymore
you've ruined the world
I think there's a lot of that kind of
just loose energy kind of milling around
like it's not like in a press group so
like politely like yeah [ __ ] right
suck a dick it's not a real group but I
think it's still so right so most people
aren't doing it but then yes why only
200 people show up and 600 protesters by
the way yeah oh yeah and the protesters
are the ones that make the whole of that
literally no we can't they have these
big marches were for Nazis show up and
then thirty thousand protesters show up
and they're like we're defending
civilization from these four and it's
just like for fat guys with helmets they
taped onto their head with like you know
like weird white supremacist signs and
they're and they're being guarded by 20
police officers to protect their free
speech and they're like they just have
to sign it up and then there's like
30,000 lesbians with green hair just
throwing rocks at these four guys and
yes like but also trying to steal their
outfit yeah it's just like oh this is
civil is in the throat milkshakes at
each other
yo I heard I heard they filled those
milkshakes with quick cement quick dry
snow but it's like it's all her that
little cylinder mint brings all the boys
like what a fat country that we're
having a desert themed he's look
chucking brownies hit each other
my cousin [ __ ] took a creme brulee to
the [ __ ] sternum the other really
what happened this ain't just [ __ ] got
out of hand
yeah relays are so good know who got
them can you say it's entertaining huh
can you say a black woman interesting
gray was it that's what I was picturing
before you vocalizes I wanted to make
sure I wasn't racist no you're not right
it's not razors just a black person's
involved in something is not race I
agree with you otherwise the whole NFL
would be racist so the whole everything
would be great why did TC he just did
they popped off [ __ ] popped off yeah
there was two restaurants near each
other dissed oh yeah we got a ramish
anything a little rapping you that's
that hurt took a ramekin to the sternum
floor number
hurts you hurt hitting the sternum yeah
real hard it [ __ ] hurt remind you
you're [ __ ] who your parents are
suddenly yeah it's true
both my parents flashed before my eyes I
get [ __ ] punches you ever you ever
forget in general like your parents are
yeah my dad's been dead a long time the
other day my pupils like oh what's up
with your dad and I was like where's my
dad man and then I was like oh yeah he
does he's crazy
so sometimes yeah I get I'll miss a
frame or two um what else we got in it I
think we'd be remiss if we did we let
Tim get out of here without letting us
know what really happened with Jeffrey
Epstein you seem to be encyclopedic yeah
I mean you know and you're rich enough
where you could get involved in this
[ __ ] yeah yeah let's hear what's going
well net we'll never know I mean that's
I mean he was clearly either murdered or
allowed to kill himself I mean that you
have narcoleptic prison guards you have
malfunctioning cameras you have him
making a will the day before he died and
you have him being taken off suicide
watch 48 hours before he died
you mean to if you don't believe there's
something going on you're in on it yeah
that's the way I feel like if you don't
believe him saying a sorry of dead yeah
I mean him having dinner last night in
West Hollywood that was a little
suspicious having a dinner party called
welcome Jeffrey to the hood that was odd
his new job at the Disney Channel
question questionable but that's what
how you'll never know what happened
football seasons common no Akash you
want to watch The Bachelor they don't
care politicians are having sex with
kids on Islands that's a fact and now no
one cares it's like doesn't matter
anymore you talked somebody the
supermarket they're like that was last
week I'm like job so politicians are
like banging kids on an island they're
like it was last week I'm all over that
so it's just a spectrum man yeah a
spectrum dude it is what it is man these
people aren't getting so rich so that
they can just keep eating steaks they
want to get involved in [ __ ] it is true
they're starting if they you know they
want to fight people from other
countries yeah you know it's right how
it starts and it escalates man it's
crazy I'm just I'm just I to me makes me
happy thinking of Bill and Hillary
Clinton sitting in their home the day he
was killed whether they knew that are
you pro-choice or pro-life when it comes
to young children having to have sex
with rich people here's the thing I
don't think young children should have
to
Sentret rich people but i don't want any
more comics right you know what I mean
so those kids got to do something I
think you bring back to work houses you
know I think what China is doing right
now is very positive with the kids
getting them in working young teach them
the value of oh and do the balancing on
each other yeah I like all that get the
kids in gym net no they shouldn't have
to [ __ ] bill clinton and alan dershowitz
yeah well you know I can ruined it you
ruin the episode I may feel differently
when I get successful though I will I be
mad that might be one of those things
where when I get really successful Mike
what was I thinking
I was such a loser yeah who knows who
would be on the undercard ear of your
belts I want him on now yeah who'd he
fight though good question let's have it
be a woman let's start small needs to be
another gay man because we can bring
back to the gave ox a what about it
grant what about a woman who's now a man
can I fight a woman a woman who's now
identifies as a man I think you guys can
if you wear matching all right let me
tell her and I will do that please beat
you people I will do that is everyone's
good for that I'm in my mat my Asian
I'll be so excited it's a like how was
that pockets I'm like you're never gonna
believe it
I'm fighting a trans person at the
Staples Center if you're like my you
excited god you're like me thank god
this is a good year this is a good year
me and Chelsea Handler about the [ __ ]
goat oh dude I would love to hit Chelsea
Handler she's two arguments away from
dropping a set of nut I saw her on a
plane the other day and she just she
looks mean she looks so mean but why do
some rich people get so mean I don't
know but she looks super mean dude she
looks like somebody would kick a service
dog yeah yeah people get lonely and mean
man that's what happens to money doesn't
make everything it really just doesn't
make everything great you know no it
doesn't it helps sometimes it helps
things yeah what they say somebody said
it helped me make you warm in the winter
and cool in the summer so that's what
somebody said right that's a poor person
saying that
it's a homeless person's idea of what
money is you get a cool war there's many
other things you guys that's an insane
that's the lowest level of what money
can do do you think you get water when
it's food when you're hungry Oh what
about a famous talk for a minute about
Fame and then we'll get out of here my
faith popularity what do you think about
it Logan man it's it's deep I mean do
you worry about it do you things you see
that where it could get out of hand for
sure yeah yeah I mean we you know we've
all seen it like Fame gets to your head
and then all sudden like these young
child actors are doing drugs and
partying and way too early and they grow
up way too fast and then they don't know
who they are when they're like 20 to 23
when you're like supposed to be
discovering yourself so yeah I mean it
um it depends on the person obviously
it's all circumstantial yeah you know I
mean but is there a difference between
like what you do in working in a written
us in an environment where it's a little
bit more people get an idea of who you
are then yeah I think so idea so say
like a J like just a worshipping of uh
an image of someone I feel like any
sense yeah yeah I'm so my [ __ ] my shits
like relatable I'm approachable you yeah
what you see on the screen is pretty
much what you get in real life you know
so people go Logan what's good I dab mop
I say what's up we joke about whatever
and that's the new faith like the old
fame is almost creepy like the old
actors who you don't know anything about
actors it's kind of creepy right cuz
it's like it's you're so used to like
guys like ham or you or anybody that is
a platform be very open in public so
when those like when you have actors it
aren't like that it's kind of strange
like that type like if you remember you
remember you remember seeing everyone's
had this experience in LA where you you
know this actor who's got the most the
bubbliest personality on screen yeah and
then you say hi to him in real life and
they're do they suck get a kid for
soft-shells suckle I think it don't yell
the share literal piece of [ __ ]
and I hate his guts I was like yell what
up Sheldon he just stared at me and I
was like I'll kick you in the chin the
neck you know what I mean thank you sir
you kick people in the neck
I could try I would have to get a train
a gay guy you can do a lot more stuff
and I know I'm not just saying you're
gay I know you're a lot of different
stuff but yeah you can as a gay man you
can kick somebody in the [ __ ] neck
and you're kind of okay with it I don't
think a straight man or you know let's
have a gay guy to get away with that
like it's the justice Millette hate
crime people happen to meet people like
oh good and if they showed my face
they'd be like two guys hit up they do
it good
no news story well good I'm glad you got
it and that next so it's like ice cream
cake guys get away with it certain gay
guys are like yeah oh good you know we
need more gay bank robbers is up
Lawrence you always wanted more gay gang
leaders yeah like that's what I wanted
gay criminals gangsters that's really
quality dude that's what I'm saying man
a lot of gay guys are just kind of
milling around the outskirts of like
real estate and [ __ ] I know there's
all of these like posh lives I'm like
get in the game yeah where are these
real [ __ ] I don't want to go to
[ __ ] milk and anti no I want putting
the clock at so much money it's gonna
happen it's gonna come good yeah I think
they already they're men yeah they were
ready yeah yeah we probably just don't
yeah you don't you don't know oh that's
true that's true don't know there's a
lot of dudes in the closet those are the
you know a lot of closeted guys yeah
yeah well Tim you [ __ ] on power the lead
of the Mexican cartel is gay in the show
I didn't say I don't [ __ ] and I said
it's for people with 75 IQs and that is
a fact it's for a simpler group of
people it is not for people that demand
a lot from entertainment yeah it's from
people that are like oh that's a
gangster and that's a gangster and then
the gangsters fight there's nothing
wrong with that
yeah um but it's a show for [ __ ]
people that drink juice box it's a very
dumb and show yeah it's very dumb and
the people who write it is very simple
yeah yeah we're gonna build an empire
okay like History Month
here's ooh here we go what is it about
what's it even about literally it's just
about are these two kids
immediately it's just you're lowering
our expectations we already have none
it's actually about two guys who grew up
together and they sell drugs oh my god
no I no idea but the guy who he grew up
with his the girl that he was in love
with when he was younger she works for
the FBI and they start dating again
billions and homeland and every ever
before they did it it was this is like
2011 it sounds good I'll start watching
that
I'll just want to go watching that in
the break room at Arby's the rest of the
crew one of the who is it though my
manager I think you heard the trans
person he's very excited
do you know what's your mana doesn't
even have the number say Bob New York
City I'm not gonna I'm gonna fire him
soon he's not getting his numbers yeah
that's nothing if he has time to call
you during the day dude he's obviously
[ __ ] not that but no he does nothing
yeah
they'll call me and it's crazy man
they'll call me for a vacation and start
talking about is the case I'm like can
you get me a [ __ ] job please yeah he
just goes it's great that's all he goes
it's great it's great
I'll talk to I go it's great I go what
is it like how many subs I think you
guys it's great I think it's great it's
like all right thanks why is he talking
lady playing hide and go seek Lee just
talk he's the last manager from the 90s
white pants mmm
you guys like me colloquy Nia's good
people yeah out of it like he has no I
didn't know Rogan was like a popular
podcast he's like you stay out of it
check that do you think going back to
like the the fame and that like it's
yeah there's something different about
like Hollywood fame and about Fame
popularity from YouTube it's almost like
they're two different things a little
bit sure yeah for sure yeah YouTube is
is weird cuz uh the drug that you get
from from getting views and likes and
subscribers and followers is it
reaffirms everything that you're doing
and so you know whether you're on the
right path or not you're gonna keep
doing the same [ __ ] as long as people
are following whereas Hollywood
technically you're employed you know so
it's let's take Tom Holland for example
before he became
spider-man there was a team around him
watching everything he did
modern monitoring every move that he'd
made just to make sure he didn't have
any missteps because now he's new Marvel
Universe and you can't you cannot [ __ ]
up right you have to be yeah you have to
be pristine you can't at that point
probably have opinions yeah for sure
yeah
you go you can have any a pity you have
to be very like bland yeah like climate
changes back yeah shove you in a limo
Hammond gee yeah peanut butter you kids
should be able to breathe good night
you're like okay this guy is great but
it's got that kind of stuff see both
feels like it's gotten so cornered that
it's just like it can't survive anyway I
feel like people want there's some
people that still watch it from you and
that because Trump came out and he said
whatever the hell he wanted and there
was something paradigm-shifting about
that it was intoxicating you were
watching him and you're like who's the
guy saying whatever he wants on the
national stage in front of everybody
how can we go back to scripted fake crap
how can you go back to an interview show
where a host is like so what are you
doing and they had celebrities the hosts
just like tell us about that time when
you were in a school play and you fell
down it's like no talk about something
real yeah because the president is going
off the dome so you need to do that too
yeah yeah it almost has challenged
entertainment in a way and I think
Entertainment hasn't really response
team entertainment has really responded
that well because they just keep seem to
keep playing some of the same old
[ __ ] like I don't know they're
doubling down they're remaking old show
yes Comedy Central thing we're remaking
Bonanza it's like this is not the move
guys it's not you know yeah it's hard
because he can do something in his house
that gets more views and and more
attention and more engagement than then
things that they're putting millions in
its weirdest it was terrifying it's
gotta be terrifying
to them yeah to them but then also
there's a but yeah there's a
relatability like I like the fact that
people that come out to my shows and
stuff they I feel like I know they're
this type of people that I would like to
meet anyway probably be okay with
meeting because they tune in for some
reason because they're into the same
kind of stuff I'm in or think it's a
much better than action
yeah much deep you have a much deeper
connection with your fans that's true
then movie star does except for that
black guy from Britain dude what's that
guy's name a kr one [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] this [ __ ] guy Jesus Christ
that's gonna be a crazy
so Staples Center what date November 9
can you jump off the ropes or it's only
punch I do whatever I want
he hit me after the Bell last night he
oh oh get a ladder Bell everybody yes he
might have been confused
he was probably watching power oh yeah
definitely yeah yeah um Nick you got
anything that's it for me yeah check out
Tim's podcast yeah don't show thanks so
funny Tim thank you yeah thanks for
having me dude yeah thank you guys you
were sick man I'll fight somebody
sometime maybe on not on this undercard
but a future yeah you could do it yeah I
mean I want to train to fight someone
now I feel like we all need to fight
people I really believe that's the only
way to really that's it I love it I
think it's a good idea mr. train who
should I fight you think Chris Chris
Thalia yeah maybe Chris I could fight I
could be Chris Lee if I'm allowed to
jump up and also punch at the same time
yeah and you can fight somebody to door
at the end of this lady I'll [ __ ] her up
I don't know dude pictures opportunity
go I'll fight back who's the guy uh I
read your dog look ripped daddy he's in
a wheelchair on Twitter I'll fight him I
like it is he
yeah it's great I'll fire all right
there you go now I'm just on the breeze
and not feeling like these leaves
oh but when I reach that round I'll
share this piece of my background I can
defeat it enough thought it's gonna take
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]